la pluie diluvienne qui allait les
arrêter parapluie dans une main et
chandelle dans l'autre des centaines de
taïwanais ont tenu à rendre hommage aux
étudiants pro-démocratie tués sur la
place tiens d'admen en 1989
militants de la première heure et jeunes
inquiet pour leur avenir la mobilisation
n'a pas d'âge
celle-ci veut aussi rappeler au
taïwanais le bilan chinois en matière de
droit de la personne à quelques mois des
élections présidentielles sur l'île des
élections à saveurs de référendum sur la
position à adopter face à la Chine
rapprochement pour éviter une invasion
ou bien défense de la souveraineté
taïwanaise
avec les tensions croissantes dans le
détroit de Taïwan ajoute celui-ci nous
avons le devoir de nous rappeler de ce
que la Chine a fait ces dernières
décennies pour bafouer les droits de la
personne ce ne sont pas que des
taïwanais qui ont bravé la pluie ce soir
nous avons rencontré des gens qui sont
venus de Macao et de Hong Kong et
territoires chinois c'est pas toujours
facile de parler à ces personnes là
parce qu'elle ne veulent pas que leur
visage soit connu elles ne veulent pas
être persécutés ou arrêter si elles
doivent retourner voir leur famille
ce petit kiosque proclame fièrement
qu'il vend des livres interdits en Chine
et ces politiques et recueillent de
poésie non loin de là le diaspora
hongkongaise continue de se battre pour
liberté en ayant une pensée pour ceux
appréhender alors qu'il voulait
commémorer le massacre de la place Tiana
cette année
ce couple a fui Hong Kong en 2020 après
l'adoption de la loi sur la sécurité il
ne se sentent pas menacés à Taïwan pour
le moment
les appels la solidarité et à la
mobilisation se font plusieurs gens
cette année ici Philippe Leblanc
Radio-Canada